alright guys bang bang I've got them
back mr. Douglas
Bonaparte how are you doing well how you
doing I'm ready to go you get your
coffee hat on you are the coffee
connoisseur and also you know you have a
side business maybe helping people with
their finances as well for those that
that didn't listen to the first episode
we did together or don't know you for
the very few just give us a little bit
of background sure so I'm the president
and founder of a wealth management firm
called bonafide wealth in downtown
Manhattan where I have not been for many
many months and don't know when I will
be back there but I specialize in
working with your now older high earning
Millennials so folks with really high
trajectory
whether it's white-collar jobs like
lawyers and doctors and Finance ears to
entrepreneurs who've you know really
boot shot from the ground up and have
really nice businesses to show for it
awesome let's just start off maybe with
like how has your world changed or what
are the conversations bend over the last
you know 1215 weeks where there's just
incredible uncertainty chaos volatility
across all these markets yeah so I'll
never for the rest of my career life
forget March particularly you know
that's that's really where the action
came on the down on the down stroke so
that was what I had been preparing for I
don't know if it was to that extent
obviously I had no idea it would be a
health crisis but I figured I would in
my career again see something like we
saw in 2008 and 2009 where I was getting
my chops in my first few years in New
York City and that was drinking out of a
fire hose I mean I was working in a
practice with pre retirees who were
freaking out and I learned a lot of
lessons I mean these were not my clients
I was working with another adviser but I
got all these free learning lessons and
I pretty much built an entire practice
to mitigate a lot of the things that I
experienced I go with a younger
clientele who's not really worrying
about retiring in a couple years so a
lot of the money we manage is really
long-term two three decades so right
then in there I know a lot of my clients
through the training that we've given
them and through the fact that a lot of
their money's qualified and long-term
I'm not gonna have a lot of that big
concern they know they can ride out
volatility even severe shocks like what
we saw on a you know 33% drawdown top to
bottom so that was that was helpful but
yeah there were still people getting
furloughed laid off very concerned lots
of calls and forced me to have to
communicate at scale so thank goodness
we have all this lovely technology and
we got a great great way to absorb
content and distribute that content and
I like to think we did a good job and
also caught a lucky break with you know
a lot of stimulus coming in propping up
the markets to where they are now that
definitely decreased a lot of the
concern that clients in the practice had
and then lastly I would say again my
clients are like me you know mid to late
30s a kid or two now you know stuck at
home with them but truth be told I'm not
at the top of the priority list right
now especially since a lot of the money
is long-term and we do most importantly
comprehensive financial planning so
everything's written down they have
their plan no one's calling me up
panicking in the middle of my even as
prices are falling or stocks are falling
so again just a mixture of all of those
things have you know again create a very
memorable March that I'll never forget
but from there forward it calmed down
significantly as we're all you know
dealing mostly with kids running around
the house and doing the daycare thing
yeah and so I guess it makes a lot of
sense that people who are a little bit
younger can weather the storm especially
if they're kind of in a good financial
position have done kind of all the you
know I kept saying like the people who
are not suffering or the people who did
the hard discipline things during the
good times they don't suffer in the bad
time the people who are freaking out or
the bad time usually didn't do the hard
discipline things and the good times and
so what were the concerns they're not
freaking out in a sense of like hey I
need the money in a year right or
anything that but like what were people
worried about giving you that there was
just uncertainty so I think it was
simply a matter of getting back to
organization how is this going to
ultimately impact a big picture and look
that is still a pretty luxurious
conversation to have when you're saying
all right how does this
change my prospects for retirement which
is 20 plus years away there was a lot of
folks revisiting cash flow and
fundamentals to see how any kind of
decrease in income so there are clients
who were asked to volunteer to drop you
know their salaries by X percent to make
sure their companies wouldn't lay off
you know more people so sacrifices were
made some even unfortunately furloughed
and laid off some part of companies that
have gone bankrupt but it goes back to
the planning that we've done and you've
said it perfectly there it's in the good
times that we prepare for the bad times
I distinctly remember writing a monthly
newsletter around that theme right there
as a matter of fact like I walk a fine
line between like worrying clients just
the right amount when things are really
good so they revisit planning they
revisit their cash reserve it's not
because I want to say told you so it's
because when it happens they're prepared
and I think the biggest thing really was
stack cash you know I'm not here to talk
about loving cash as an asset and what
inflation can do to it I'm talking about
sleeping well at night and nobody is
going to convince me that a fat stack of
cash like nine to twelve months of your
living expenses by the way that's well
beyond that three to six months rule of
thumb you keep hearing about nine to
twelve so when things were really good
and bonuses were fat and you know the
ability to bulk these very foundational
things up we're there we instructed
folks to do just that and look that
comes in handy when your income poof
vanishes or gets cut by twenty thirty
percent no one was worried about their
ability to get from you know February to
now June and you know this markets
pretty crazy the economy no one really
has their finger I mean people are
getting hired and buying homes I've yet
to see someone like be unable to sell
their home and buy a home in this crazy
time which is kind of unfathomable and
then again you know you have people
losing jobs economy on the other hand is
just in shambles so I was somebody the
other day and I say joked because I
couldn't believe that this was fact but
I said if I told you at the beginning of
this year that there was gonna be a
global pandemic 47 million Americans
were gonna lose
jobs but personal income would go up
over ten percent savings rate would go
thirty three percent and the housing
market would go up you would literally
take that bet all day long that it was
impossible for that to happen and yet
here we are yeah yeah it was really
really crazy yeah it's funny because in
in some regards I feel like this is just
a scaled-up extreme version of what o is
is like it's easier to say you know back
before co vid like oh you know this
happened because of this of course
so now scale that up like everything
should be falling apart I think we've
been saying that for literally a hundred
plus days and you know either on a
day-by-day week-by-week month-by-month
you're just looking at the markets
people like what is happening I don't
know how many tweets and jokes I've made
to that extent but on the other side
look how extreme the response to that
has been the trillions of dollars and
stimulus so you know rather it's just a
completely gassed up extreme version of
that same ping-pong game we play almost
every day in the markets you know and
one thing good one thing bad another
thing good another thing bad what is it
all net out to I mean if your long-term
and optimistic positive right like
that's the bull case if you're bearish
and like want to see that you then you
got the other side so we play the same
game we played pre cove it as we are
right now it just seems a lot more
extreme so one of the things that the
virus has done is it's kind of exposed a
lot of shams in society and then it's
also magnified a lot of trends that were
already underway and you received this
blog post about access without knowledge
is dangerous and we usually we're
talking about is kind of a macro trend
of the barriers to entry and friction
being reduced in terms of getting really
retail traders into a public market
investing most people historically have
said that's a good thing right and kind
of for all the reasons that people would
assume I think you're saying something a
little nuance which is access isn't
necessarily good or bad it's is it
access with knowledge and so maybe kind
of talk through a little
what you wrote and kinda with the
driving thought process behind that was
yeah absolutely so clearly the talk of
the town in the investment community is
what we see going on with Robin Hood
traders or pajama traders fueled by Wall
Street bats and Dave Portnoy and all the
ruckus taking place right now you know
stocks only go up if you miss the dip
you're an idiot Warren Buffett's out you
know every hedge fund guy who's made it
in the Hall of Fame out you know the new
kids are here we're taking over
that's probably said how many times over
every decade this this isn't new but
what is new is the level of access that
is now being provided to get into the
capital markets and you're seeing that
through obviously Robin Hood and I think
overall net positive on providing access
like you can have participants who never
could participate before they said
investing was a rich man's game right
you needed a broker you needed to go
through someone to get there and you
needed minimums to do it well now you
can do it for free and for dollars so I
think that's a good thing but when it
goes unchecked when you don't possess
the fundamental knowledge necessary to
control that you can really put yourself
into some precarious situations and it
reminded me a lot of what was going on
with student loans so my wife and I
wrote a book almost three years ago now
called the Millennial money fix which
was about the student loan crisis I was
watched her take on you know multiple
six figures in student loan debt to go
to law school where it was pretty much
like hey if you take out the debt pay
for this education there's a big law job
waiting for you even if you hate law you
know you'll be making this much money
you're making six figures pay off your
debt go find something else to do but if
you do like it you can make you know
partner somewhere and millions of
dollars and all of that okay um what
happened 2008 and 2009 happened it
happened to the later end of our
generation so the impetus to write the
book was simply about you know what is
going on here how did we as a generation
fall into what seems to be a trap
obviously we couldn't have called the
great financial crisis or the financial
recession
in 2008 but he created this idea that
access in this case education and access
to student loans debt without
understanding how you're gonna get an
ROI on that education was actually doing
like due diligence and critical thinking
about it it's not hard to do that it's
just you're thrown the promise like
you're gonna get a job so we we examined
that we took a historical approach where
student loans came from and now
mirroring that here it is again you know
here we have it with access to the
financial markets from folks who don't
have lot you know what happens if you
don't forget the knowledge of how the
difference between a stock in a bond
market caps assets you know fundamental
value to forget all of that for a second
you can go deep dive into investments
what about just knowing what your goals
are and having a system for that
what about mastering cash flow how money
comes in and out of your life so you
know what your savings rate is and you
know where you're able to save and you
know the goals you're saving for and
then prioritizing those goals we call
this earning the right to invest I want
people to essentially earn the right to
invest equip themselves with the
foundational knowledge that they need to
then go invest and do so not just
responsibly but do it in a way that they
can stay invested I want you to stay in
I want you to make money I'm thrilled
absolutely thrilled anyone would go into
the markets and come out making money
assuming it's not all on paper like you
actually had something to show for it
right so with Robin Hood we have this
construct now just like we did with
student loans where dangerous things are
happening so just like the the students
who borrowed money hit the recession and
now our bag holders and can't get income
high enough to overcome their monthly
payment or get relief for that their
severely lagging on their ability to
accomplish their financial goals that's
the pain point and when you're young
you're not thinking about your financial
goals
you're really not you're young I get it
I you know you and I have both been in
that position you feel invincible you
want to go explore and travel I want you
to do those things too but I don't want
you to blow yourself up so that you
can't retire some day that you can't
build an emergency fund that you
can't buy a house cuz you're gonna get
married and you want to have kids I mean
these are evergreen goals that we almost
universally share as human beings and
Americans to do great things in life I'm
not here to tell you to specifically do
those things but I do want you to find
what it is you're going after would you
rather just drift you know throughout
your life paycheck to paycheck I hope
not
I hope not so yeah I see it happening
again and I wrote this piece
specifically about access without
knowledge and what you saw in the most
extreme form unfortunately was a 20 year
old who committed suicide because they
really didn't understand how to read the
cash balance for the options trading
that they were doing and which made the
story even all that more sad is they
weren't in the whole seven hundred
thirty thousand dollars which by the way
would have dramatically and you know we
would have changed anyone's life how are
you coming back from that
even though there are actual remedies to
help yourself there it's the saddest
story you could possibly paint in this
situation and you know we were just
talking about extremes earlier okay
that's an extreme but what about all the
gray area between no access and so much
access that you literally lose your life
right so we gotta we gotta close that
gap and the only way to do that is
really through the financial education
component the financial knowledge and
literacy component that hopefully people
can establish before they go running
into the capital markets I point out
that we've really you know gamified and
casino fied the entire thing here it
doesn't help you know that a media mogul
is saying stocks go up it doesn't help
and he doesn't though its marketing
that's marketing you know I dunk on the
Robin Hood traders from marketing just
myself I'm not gonna be a hypocrite
about that but I'm doing it to then
bring that attention over to the actual
financial literacy you know people say
what you know that's not nice you're
just jealous you missed the dip like
that's the response like I assure you I
did not but what I want you to do is
understand that this is cool this is
very cool when you do it responsibly and
I want you to do that so you can stay in
and be successful in achieve your goals
one of the things you know with portly
that I think it's really interesting is
he absolutely looks like the holiday of
like stocks goes up right he's saying it
from like each individual stock price
goes up right and in the way that it I
think it's received the crazy thing is
he's not wrong if he caveated it with
stocks only go up when the Federal
Reserve is printing tons of money and
inflating asset prices right to your
point like the education component is
the explanation of that right and so
it's this weird thing where the
structural components of the stock
market or working in the favor of asset
prices going up and so of course
whenever there's high-level volatilities
and anyone who's long can just literally
wake up and keeps making money it pulls
everybody in because everyone wants to
get rich quick right yeah yeah I guess
as part of this like what do you think
the solution for knowledge is is this a
thing where you know the Robin Hood's
the Ito rose whoever it is of the world
they basically have to say you can sign
up for an account but we're gonna make
you take a tutorial before you you can
actually start trading is it something
where maybe there's a limited exposure
until you do certain things on an
education basis is it just we say hey
look it's not their responsibility as
private companies but instead we need to
teach this in schools like how do we
solve the problem yeah it's a
multi-faceted to answer a lot of the
things you just said our components you
know to solving this and it's a massive
problem and I sincerely doubt that me as
one person has all the answers but I do
have an idea towards some of the things
that can be done to help solve this
problem I think you know you get a big
calling from a lot of people that we
know to put financial education and
literacy programs in schools like you'll
take AP statistics but you can't you
know understand the difference between a
stock and a bond or more importantly
reconcile six months worth of expenses
can't like get people in the practice of
that so yes putting it in the schools
would be very helpful regulation would
be very helpful either self regulation
and I think what Robin Hood ended up
doing and
response to that event was putting in
greater controls over option three level
excuse me level three option training on
different questionnaires things like
that how about just showing you like hey
before you do this before you hit trade
you know here's max up here's max down
are you sure like show people that and
you brought up a good point what's their
incentive to do that
they're not fiduciaries now I'm not
going to go as far as to say like are
they putting people in collections and
going after assets like they literally
have an incentive to watch them fail so
they can go get so I'm not saying that
I'm saying they don't have an incentive
because they're not a fiduciary you know
they're their incentive is to have you
trade and to make money as a business
but I will argue this there is likely
more long-term value to generate by
educating your consumer by not only
being a place that you can access
financial markets but that you can also
educate yourself right just I think
there's um a way to expand your platform
and find other money-making
opportunities and other lines of
businesses on top of having a more
educated client I have clients that use
Robin Hood to take five to ten percent
of their investable money and go nuts
and by the way going nuts to them is
like buying Apple or Microsoft they're
like their favorite companies that are
probably not gonna do all that bad they
like don't have time to go Yolo you know
you know go on some Tesla Yolo calls
here like it's not what they're even
doing but you know they have a plan in
place they have all these things so back
to like what Robin Hood can do and what
brokerages can do or any financial
technology company can do is regulate
themselves a little bit better and then
I think you can go as high as like will
we see regulation you know from from our
government on down that's even tougher
and I think truthfully what we've seen
here is that financial technology in
many regards FinTech is outpacing
regulation like acts written in the 30s
and 40s did not anticipate you being
able to swipe a disclosure click it
margin boom liked it it was you're going
to sit down with this person and
fill out a bunch of paperwork you know
and hit all these stopgaps
before you would go do something and you
know not every investment advisor is a
saint you know we all have to go too far
back in history to find out you know
folks that have led clients into making
some very bad financial decisions if not
just criminal you know behavior I'm not
saying that but I am saying a hey at
least there were stop gaps and
procedures and compliance offices and
you know regulations that stuck a little
bit harder because yeah they were they
were older processees so yeah you got
education in the schools
you got self-regulation because you want
to have a better business and better
enterprise and then you have perhaps
regulation in the form of law to ensure
that people are safe those are three
great ways to go about this it's tough I
think to you know get this into the
household like if your mom and dad and
Grandma and Grandpa weren't savvy or
don't know this stuff I think it's
really hard for them to then go get it
and teach it to the kids um but let me
flip this for a second if there's
anything I can say as maybe a bit of a
silver lining um from 2008-2009 and even
what we're seeing right now at least the
period of time between the recession and
now there has been and it's hard to deny
this a uptick in thirst for this kind of
knowledge I think you're seeing it and
get mutated a little bit with the you
know whole stock trading thing right now
but you know when you get punched in the
face you know when you're a bag holder
of student loan debt and you saw you
know everyone getting left behind
you saw your you know brother not get
hired or laid off or mom and dad lose
their business yeah that kind of trauma
you know that will stigmatize a person
and start having you go out and finding
you know solutions or making sure you
don't fall into similar traps so I would
love to really just hit the hit this
thing even harder right now that there
is at least the first time I've seen a
real quest to you know get financially
literate
yeah and it's this crazy thing we're
like I've always talked about it from
the accredited investor standpoint of
like we use basically how rich are you
as a proxy for like how smart are you
and so it feels like financial education
would be a great way to kill two birds
with one stone like make everyone take I
don't know it's gonna be like as a
cumbersome as like the SAT but like the
driving test wasn't that bad right so
like hey come in answer some questions
if you pass like okay you're not an
idiot and you you have some base level
of knowledge like knock yourself out
take whatever risk you want it also
feels like that is a great way to
structurally start to add financial
education into the system as well so one
you can open up different asset classes
for people that maybe previously aren't
available but to also it's a great way
for without coming in and like mandating
and saying you know Douglas you need to
have a you know four-year degree before
you could buy a stock like yeah we're
getting anywhere near that but I do
think that a way to kind of seed it is
you basically put things behind that
obstacle that people want and say look
here's a path to a certain asset classes
you don't have available with you today
if you go get this education here's you
know 20 different ways you can get it
somewhere free some are paid and knock
yourself out and you're off the races at
least it's a step in the right direction
I don't know if it solves all the
problems it probably doesn't but it just
feels like that is somewhere that we
could go that that's relatively not
controversial and could also you know
really have a positive impact well again
you know it comes down to the businesses
themselves and thinking about the kind
of long-term you know business that they
want to have for themselves you know if
you if you think if you can get behind
this idea that there's more value that
you can generate as a business by
informing your customers right and this
is what's there's at least this
advantage that make if regulation hasn't
caught up to you yet and it's a little
bit of Wild West you know what we see so
many times is people go to the nefarious
things right oh let's shove these
products into people's faces you know
credit default swaps you know and stuff
like that you don't have to again go too
far back to see like the market always
goes for the path of least resistance
cuz that's where the money is gonna be
made that kind of behavior is really you
know where the trouble begins you can
instead perhaps use that to test out the
market oh like if you're just a little
they're like oh my goodness people are
getting in trouble like Robin Hood has
the data like they know how many people
are trading crazy options you know they
know who's racking up debits in their
account they know their age assuming
they filled it out they that's their tax
ID they have everything on you they know
this inside and out and are they going
there's money to be made on these rubes
or they going like huh we're making
money here but this is not good long
term like let's try and incorporate
these following systems and see what the
result is oh it doesn't make as much
money today but it will create a more
loyal customer over time we'll get that
many more trades or that much more
transaction volume by having them stick
around further and we did the right
thing so there's a corporate governance
and sustainability and responsibility
component that really needs to be added
to any time you have access to something
and the lack of knowledge can put people
in a very precarious situation I
couldn't agree more I asked for
questions on Twitter before we did this
because of course everyone on Finn - it
has has an opinion or has ideas of what
we should talk about one of the
questions came from Kathryn Cole which
was what is the best net income growth
story of someone that you've worked with
obviously don't use any names but I just
kind of tell us one of those stories so
it's usually from and I'll paint with
somewhat of a broad brush because it
happens over it's not any one person
it's usually a group of people you'll
find this with the folks who had the
courage to leave their job you know
which was not bringing them satisfaction
and go down the entrepreneurial road and
pursue the passion that they had when it
seemed in the early they do it typically
the better like it's harder to do this
when you have kids and mouths to feed
and a mortgage and stuff like that but
I'm even more impressed by those who are
like despite all of that you know and
there's planning that can be done around
that like maybe maybe you stick it out
for two three years you know have all
that retirement savings go to cash
savings build up that runway so you can
go do that but it's usually around the
entrepreneurs who go all-in on
themselves and you know they work their
tails off and
got seven-figure businesses to show for
it like they would never ever ever have
made that kind of money doing what they
were doing I mean they could have been
an accountant you know and now you know
now they're selling you know the thing
that they love most in this world on
Amazon they have an Amazon business or
they just have an online shop and
they're making a good at home oh it's
just the coolest stuff you could ever
see and and to help be a part of that I
mean I can't take a lot of credit I mean
they're the ones who did that work but
if if I could give them encouragement or
show them a roadmap to at least
financially afford doing that without
like their kids starving going on you
know I as their advisor in getting a
continued client who's loyal is the
greatest satisfaction you could have
yeah and I guess how do you think about
from the advisors see there's a big talk
in the tech community now about like
raise venture capital don't raise
venture capital bootstrapping a cash
flow kind of you know seek profitability
early all these different things and a
lot of people don't get to ask like the
financial advisors how do the financial
advisors think about that for someone's
portfolio right in terms of are you
actually dry driving cash from a cash
flow business that's profitable and
you're taking like a annual dividend
type situation or is it hey look you're
gonna have very little cash flow for a
number of years but you're building up
this illiquid equity that one day should
be worth you know much more than it is
today on paper but how do you think
about that yeah it's a great point I
mean it's mostly bootstrapping at least
from you know the position of my clients
they're grabbing whatever cash and
resources they have really minimizing
their expenses so you know they're
fairly uncomfortable but surviving and
they go all-in on themselves and build
this thing out to where their cash flows
can pay them either greater salaries or
they can do that plus a combination of
dividends and before you know it if
they've worked it right and had a great
plan and executed you know money's not a
problem right and you get two you get
two benefits you get cash flow to be
able to pay all your bills and squirrel
money away while watching the value of
your business rise and you know
hopefully at some point start talking
about terminal value but they might I
got clients that love what they do they
love their business they only want to
talk about that like they're having fun
that's the win the win is enjoying your
life and I think that's you know key to
our generation and demographic is fine
the purpose and making money with your
purpose why would you stop why would you
stop it's hard to it's hard to put
yourself in the shoes of 60 70 55 year
old you and say what you're going to do
then you know as someone who's built a
business themselves I can't even like
what do you want to do next year I'm
like do I really need to answer that
question right now
do I need to scale up five six financial
advisers and staff of 20 and worry about
real estate when I get to watch my kids
grow up handle a hundred households that
I enjoy working with still grow maybe
I'll wake up tomorrow and say you know
what let's do that five times over and
there's a price to pay for that right
it's maybe not seeing my daughter's
dance recital cuz I gotta go put out a
fire of advisor number 24 and you know
there's eight billion dollars in assets
on the line it sounds glamorous right I
know I once read a white paper from it
was six billion plus dollar are eye-gaze
and the whole white paper was about how
to replicate what they've done and build
your own multi-billion dollar RIAA I
finished reading it and I stared up at
the ceiling for like a good hour going
no like god no like no no no and it
wasn't because I was late as like do you
really want to do this and I started
thinking about the sacrifices these
individuals made to get there and the
same could be said for any fortune 500
company CEO go ask Jamie Dimon what he
does and does not get to do in his
personal life because he's running
JPMorgan like I'm always under the
impression that all of these people we
you know glamorize you know who are
running amazing companies unless you're
in their shoes you really don't
understand the sacrifices that they make
is often their health their
relationships I see that in my clientele
too so partners of firms right maybe
they're divorced once or twice already
then I know some of them don't get to
see their kids I you know I'm not
knocking it this their lives not mine
but anyways that's my take on you know
entrepreneurs as clients and even myself
and the decisions that you make from a
generational standpoint you know I think
we're really what's so character
characteristically us is that we're
willing to disrupt and redefine
conventional ways in which we've done
things and we're given such a har
time for that like do it it's that
classic like do it my way or not
specifically in wealth management is is
you know one of the old oldest of Oldboy
you know clubs around you get a solo
practitioner from the brokerage era who
is sling in stocks is now 65 bringing up
a junior advisor like and you say hey I
want to start a blog and do video
content it's like no you get pushback on
that you and I both know that that's the
way like if you don't build that
business on the internet and direct
traffic right I remember the first day a
lead came through you know my you know
my Wow when a lead came through just
from web traffic um and I was like oh my
god the machine works right as funnel
funnel is the word I was looking for so
you know it was junk but like the
machine worked and now I can apply and
move these things around and oh my god
now today you know to get as as a solo
practitioner as someone with only you
know one staff to be able to get
anywhere from two to six viable leads a
month like do that two years you can
hire someone
I can't sustain that and not bragging if
six years of doing that so yeah there's
a lot of those issues getting off-topic
here but a lot of those issues here when
we think about entrepreneurs and growing
income and the ways in which we do stuff
for sure and I guess help me understand
Teddy rode in and he was like look
what's the advantage over an adviser a
human adviser versus kind of a Robo
advisor or the Robin Hood places in the
world I think I know what your answer is
gonna be but kinda how do you think
about the the difference there yeah um
I'm kind of getting tired of people not
recognize it don't mean it I'm getting
what I'm getting tired of is advisors
not admitting to themselves and to
others that the retail investment space
is not monetized like it's like what did
Robo advisors show you it
exactly that the commoditization of this
space which is a big threat to advisors
who are simply running risk-adjusted
portfolios because you can go get that
you know through a robo you can do it
yourself right you do for free you don't
even need to pay the 25 basis points or
less to do that where and I think by the
way for for down market for folks who
don't want to pay you know thousands of
dollars or have the complexity in their
financial life to need that detailed
analysis you can do this all for free
you can do this all super cheap and I
would encourage people to do that you
know you always get the advisors for
like the robos will never replace me I
Got News for You if you're just doing
investment advisory and creating these
ETF portfolios which we do for our
clients for for you know just basic
asset allocation that is something we
offer if that is all you're doing you're
going to be in for a rude awakening over
the next 10 20 years some people say if
not sooner fine pick your timeframe I'm
already telling you like that's gonna be
trouble but when you bring in financial
planning and advice you know you can't
you know you bring in a human
relationship you bring in someone who
understand your unique financial
situation not just to create the
financial plan and go through the six
key areas of financial planning as the
CFP Board would prescribe very important
stuff very helpful to organize people in
that way but when you get that basis
that document and then you can have
conversations with someone based on
their real life that ties back to that
plan yeah that value just can't be
replicated you know through an algorithm
or through a piece of software it even
can't be replicated if you know you are
a Robo offering financial planning and
advice hey Steve you call up next time
it's Mary like were they passing your
financial plan around and expect to
really understand that at that point so
maybe over time it will separate you
know those with enough sophistication
that need comprehensive financial
planning and the estate planning and the
tax planning and all of that from those
who simply just need to focus on their
cash flow be disciplined with saving and
systematically invest their money into a
risk-adjusted portfolio that's fine you
know that's fine so I use a robo in
conjunction with this I think it solves
of problems for advisors who needs a
scale up investment advisory and do it
the right way and can pass savings on to
their client so it's an in conjunction
thing it's never like a versus B but
let's just you know let's just call it
as it is like investment advisory for
these types of portfolios you know very
low cost ETF passive portfolios is
commoditized but very powerful when you
pair it with financial planning I love
it
where's bit coin and crypto fit into all
this what are your kind of current views
there what do you see your clients
wanting to do or yeah more and more
clients come in with a crypto position
um with some knowledge so there's a
definite uptick in that not as much as
you would think
um yeah one in ten you know have have
experience which is sweet I mean it's
really cool that's you know four years
ago is you know one in none you know
once in a while I was on crypto tales
podcasts live from Iowa awesome podcast
he's a great host and he and I chopped
it up specifically about that like and
I've even been with you and Marc at a at
a lunch you know getting off 1% like and
I think that pretty much captures like
what we need to do but my biggest
problem is this until SEC and FINRA or
regulators come and say here is the
prescribed methodology that will let an
investment adviser make the
recommendation to put this in a
portfolio you know it is a it is very
worrisome if you're the chief compliance
officer or if you answer to a compliance
officer of how to do that so we can
educate we can we can talk to our
clients about how their positions work
in conjunction with their portfolios we
can show them risk we can show them
potential reward we can show them all
that based on what they've done you know
but for me and even though I might want
to say yeah there's awesome debt out
there just 1% you know of a portfolio
Bitcoin of what it can do yes you'll
have more volatility that that much is
true
but as a diversifier as an asset class
that has never really been used you know
in in portfolios before like it has a
tremendous amount of potential I just
don't have the rulebook
you know I so
it's really just risk management from a
firm level like you don't want to get
audited and saying hey I'm looking at
this financial plan and it says you know
a diversified portfolio of crypto
currencies you know whether it's Bitcoin
or anything else or douche going I think
you what what in there um but I would
say this you know and we talked about
this previously I mined Bitcoin back in
2014 so I have my own story with
familiarizing myself with it I've been
toying with it for quite some time I
would say toying with it I've literally
held it since 2014 my friend called me
up say you know started going on crazy
about hashing and a computer and mining
and blockchain never heard this stuff in
my life before I could tell he was just
looking for money like he wanted money
from me he wanted to go do something and
I wanted to get him off the phone so I
just we just came back from art my wife
and I came back from her honeymoon we're
like really cash poor at the moment and
I know no better way to get someone off
the phone who's asking for money than
say let me talk to my wife so I
literally go I go hey Heather sets on
the phone you know he's looking to put
money into some kind of super computer
Oh Seth yeah give him the money I'm like
what like totally blindsided a super
smart guy is like when these
neurobiologists type focu you can't have
a normal conversation with so my wife's
impression is like he knows something
you know with some crazy technology that
we don't and is probably worth the shot
so he won that day months later you know
we get a Tutera hash miner I'm like look
I'm limited partner you set it up create
a wallet for me
cool this you know pull the hashing and
just drop the coins in my account well
six bitcoins later each not bad right
$3,000 a piece for a miner you know I
think Bitcoin was worth 400 bucks you
know at the time and I was like um it's
so funny the miner itself so I don't
think I felt this part of the story the
miner itself your contract to receive
the miner itself was worth ten thousand
dollars on eBay so you're buying a
$6,000 miner that you know basically you
had a derivative of Bitcoin you could
just sell it for ten times I'm like dude
that's the play go sell our contract and
we'll go buy the Bitcoin like
stupid here and he's like no no you're
not gonna ruin my fun I want to set this
up I want to mine it I want to do this
I'm like he goes remember you're the
limited partner I'm like okay GP you
call the shots this is dumb if your goal
is to make money
you're being very stupid right now and
you're a bad general partner but let's
go with it you know you're running the
show
anyways flash-forward you know now it's
like December 2017
you know I got six plus figures in
Bitcoin what that you know my friends
are getting millionaires unbelievable
you know womp you know I think that's
like the second drawdown of 80 plus
percent you either then or you know then
again after and my attitude towards us
the entire time was like I'm playing
with house money every day that I have
it I have the privilege of going through
any environment you know whistling Dixie
and whatever it will be if it goes to
zero like let's say you know it turned
out to be one giant Ponzi scheme by the
way I do not think that at all I think
it's here to stay it's hard to say like
this thing's anything but real but if it
went to zero I probably will have the
best jokes on Twitter and troll everyone
including myself and I will laugh and if
it goes to some absurd value in the
future I will also laugh but to the bank
right so um it's win-win for me um it's
very fun watching you know what's going
on there needs to be more applications
when it comes to Bitcoin I'm looking for
a store of value digital gold that's a
selfish opinion you know obviously I
have I have some and I think that's a
really good purpose for it
blockchain technology really should be
you know taking care of things like real
estate transactions anywhere that you've
been signing you know you buy a house
and you're sitting in a title office and
you're like what am I doing here you
know if you've had any experience with
anything related to crypto currencies or
blockchain you're just like doesn't that
solve this problem and where is it so I
think we're probably got a lot of time
to go I think we're way ahead of the
curve here but that's my opinion and I'm
gonna see more and more of it in client
portfolios I'm going to be forced to
have to have an opinion I
suggest any financial adviser to go read
white papers and get foundational
understanding I know a lot but compared
to you and everyone who's like really in
love with this space I'm humbled every
single time with really just how little
I know and if I relatively know a lot
compared to everybody else that is just
a huge gap that needs to be filled so
what people can do you know go get cash
up and go go get a you know go get some
Satoshi's like fool the rent
tinker with it you know you learned you
learned your iphone you learned how to
drive a car there's no reason you can't
play around with this and see what it is
because when clients if you're an
advisor if clients are coming in and the
difference I can't tell you how many
relationships I've secured because of
that story because I was able to say you
know I I ran into a guy um who worked
for a crypto trading desk previously
before doing FX and I'm pretty you know
we spent 20 minutes outside of the
regular pitch just talking about crypto
currencies and what our experiences were
became because of that because of that
and and honestly it doesn't and because
he did that for a living previously
doesn't have any cashed out just needed
planning for his wife and kids and to
retire someday so here we are a plan
that has nothing to do with crypto
currencies but a relationship that was
secured because of it I love it I
absolutely love it
somebody else asked what's the worst
investment you've ever made Oh wasn't
luck in coffee I did not buy any of that
the worst investment I've made there
there's a few of them I think there was
this there was our cap you know five six
years ago I forget the the guy who did
that it was it was a real estate holding
company I had hardly anything in there
there is something recently that oh yeah
it was med med it was med med it was
like my first play in cannabis and like
obviously cannabis will be absolutely
massive like when my kids are old enough
it should be my kids are older you know
I can't see
world where you know this isn't like
they're not going to be thinking about
weed like we did you know when we were
it'll be federally illegal you know or
just like no one will really care like
at that point however it gets dealt with
and what I thinking with men men um you
know is held as the iPhone or Apple
store of weed you know being in New York
you could walk by the store on Fifth
Avenue I flew out to California for a
conference and I was going through you
know going through Hollywood and boom
there were stores all over the place and
they were packed and as I was like cool
like then this is cool you know this is
a this has promise just based on that
small position and you know down down we
go
I actually practice what I preach with
investments you know just long-term
risk-adjusted here and there I'll find
you know opportunities to invest in that
are probably more private placement than
they are you know trading stocks but you
know some winners and losers hopefully I
generate a little bit of alpha but
that's probably in recent years the
worst investment that I've made I love
it I tend to agree with you I think the
the marijuana space is going to in
hindsight appear to be a no-brainer how
you gonna pick how you gonna pick that
amongst like you know ten twenty company
I bet the winner is one that's not even
you know formed yet you know I've got
the one like that is the Amazon of wheat
or whatever the Microsoft of wheat
doesn't even exist right now is there a
weed ETF yet yeah I think it was there
was one MJN a I think obviously you know
go do your research before you look up
any ticker symbols here but there was
one nothing I've ever seen a client
invest in or nothing I've personally
invested in despite really believing in
this space and knowing it's gonna be
massive I mean there you go I mean
there's your buyer beware I have yet to
see someone
I've seen people hit it out of the park
with crypto more than I've seen people
hit it out of the park with marijuana
what does that tell you crazy crazy and
in prowl and looking and I tend to think
that that's actually you know makes
sense in some weird way last question
for you
is if you were sitting today let's call
it under the age of 30 and you had to
put all of your net worth in one single
asset class what asset class are you
choosing and why so you have a long time
your long term horizon and you have to
have the most conviction because 100%
your net worth scaling and you're gonna
hold it for that long period of time
what what is not necessarily I don't
care about the company or the stock
right now I'll give you a sector III go
for technology you know I just as
someone who's grown up with the computer
in front of that it's you know who's
gonna argue that you know like think
about that like oh man I went all-in on
like retail like and it didn't work out
like yeah no [ __ ] you know like you see
how many boxes you got a kid you see how
many boxes I read a funny joke the other
day um it was the UPS guy knocked on our
door to see if we were okay because an
Amazon box wasn't delivered that day you
know anyways um you know technology is
what defines our lives you and I are
doing this right here on zoom' right now
you know you have an iphone in your hand
all the things I wish I had as a kid or
like you watch it yeah you I remember
watching Inspector Gadget being my
favorite show as a kid my brother and I
glued to his screen watching penny with
her computer book I remember getting
those black-and-white journals and
making computer books like you know I
remember watching The Simpsons in the
future and big Simpsons fan watching the
episode you know where Lisa's in the
future and Mary's I was a Hugh Grant but
ends up Merritt yeah it was Hugh Grant
um I guess sorry that's how much I know
this stuff and you know they were doing
a video call you know and I was just
like we got we're gonna get that we're
gonna or like will we ever get that we
do have it we have it's even like
Jetsons like all this stuff right like
it's coming and now the equivalent of
that isn't like some cartoon right that
like The Simpsons are gonna predict the
future even though they continue to do
that pretty well
it's more of like the black mirror stuff
like yeah you know I demanded a friend
reason I said if you watch every single
episode of black mirror which I have
knocked on but just take generally its
futuristic kind of you know fiction
sci-fi stuff what percentage of that
stuff is true in the next twenty years
and fifty percent probably Minority
Report is probably one of my favorite
look into the future movies even though
I'm on cruise control um it's probably
the last one I'll watch but yeah there's
a lot of things going on in there
autonomous cars are in there that was
the big one you know you just if you
want to go for a drive go into the
countryside but otherwise you're
plugging into you know a grid um Precog
all that kind of stuff I've been for now
weeks and months trying to you know
craft some kind of teleporter or
teleportation joke because of what's
going on with the airlines like like
I'll be the one you know let me be the
first to say it like teleporters like
it's not you know alright now we're
getting is some pretty crazy physics
stuff but look if we can you know
FaceTime all of our buddies and you know
have a drink and if you said that 20
years ago you get laughed at who knows
so that's why I say technology clearly
buying like a technology you know ETF um
I mean rule of thumb how many of those
companies will not be around you know
how concentrated are you towards you
know fan favorites and Fang stocks
quieted quite a big deal someone posted
a chart today like in two thousand what
the top ten companies were in my market
cap and I think the only one maybe was
one or two but only one that was there
that's still here today
it was Microsoft I think it was that's
the only one that hung around it was
interesting to see the comparison
between the two oh by the way the PE the
collected p/e of the top ten components
cheaper today than two thousand so we
got you know everyone in college we got
a tech ball you got room to go if mm
your barometer of when this thing pops
who knows who knows I love it I mean
look and it's just again you said in the
beginning so much of this stuff is is
not new right so I tend to think that
it's where we look at it we're on where
can we send people to find you on the
internet or learn more about the wealth
management yeah if you if you want
find me and just you know laugh a lot go
to the twitter account at doug bonaparte
if you're interested in anything having
to do with financial advisory free
financial literacy content or just want
to chop it up about the industry i like
talking to young advisors who are like
how do i get in how do I grow up
practice because it's insanely hard to
do given the massive transition going
from broker era to this new era of
Finance plane
vice bonafide wealth dot-com Google the
name you'll you'll land on it reach out
I'm around awesome man
listen I appreciate you taking the time
to do this I always get a few laughs and
learn something so well did you get in
the future thanks for having me well